hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith and today we're gonna
take you for a stroll down the most
fashionable walkway in Hollywood the
Oscars red carpet we're gonna give you a
sneak peek at how all the magic happens
and then give you a sense of what it's
actually like to walk the red carpet on
Oscar Sunday strap on your high heels
and join us as we go inside the Oscars
red carpet the Oscars red carpet is the
most active most energetic most
celebrated red carpet in the world the
red carpet is in the heart of Hollywood
we are between Highland and Orange on
Hollywood Boulevard it's a very
intricate 500 feet long and thirty three
feet wide it is the biggest red carpet
in the world and it takes over 800
man-hours to install all elements so it
is a very large undertaking the red
carpets consisted of multiple stumps hey
you have the limo drop yes get out of
their cars at Hollywood Boulevard they
can't believe they're actually arriving
they're actually at the Oscars that
initial moment is kind of a shock to the
system then we have a secured area we go
through and then you're on the red
carpet and it's amazing and electric it
is Sixth Sense overload you have the
entire press line and the entire
bleacher seats and everyone's yelling at
your name
it's capacity when it comes to a point
where you can't move there's a lot of
people in the carpet it's very loud you
can't hear yourself think it can be a
bit intimidating for people there's lots
of people that I get very nervous and
they're about to leave the tent it's not
just the new ones it's the people that
I've done it every year on one side of
the carpet is more than 2,000 meter
professionals and the other side is
about 700 hardcore Oscar fans that come
from all over this country and some
travel international AIDS and they're
part of our show that day the red carpet
I always say is a bit of controlled
chaos we have a general side where most
of our guests go into the theater and
experience the show and then we have a
press line side which is where the
nominees and the presenters and the
performers go if they're our nominee
they're going down the press line if you
hit most the outlets it's gonna take you
over two hours to get down that carpet
most the time it's just go down the line
as it but then since we're a live show
there are certain times where they have
pre-booked Talent there are three stages
along the way that talent is pulled to
or pre-arranged to do interviews that it
is weeks and weeks of scheduling
nominees and scheduling presenters and
performers and where they need to be at
certain times on each stage the carpet
is so vast it can't be done with just
one host there are multiple hosts we
want to build the tension build the
excitement build the glamour it's trying
to give it some sort of thematic through
line and last year we decided to
celebrate costume design we went to the
archives of the Academy and we found all
these incredible sketches costumes
throughout history they're red carpets
the first thing people see in the red
carpet and pre-show is as big as the
show inside to be on the red carpet with
some of you know the biggest filmmakers
in the world it's pretty amazing a lot
of times there's reunions happening in
the midst of chaos it's nice to see
those moments walking down the Oscar red
carpet is unlike anything that anybody's
ever experienced it's kind of like
ascending to Mount Olympus
it's like Valhalla you are
with the movie gods it is some dreamlike
experience because you're at the height
of glamour you're at the height of the
business because to get to the Oscars is
the aspirational dream of anybody that's
associated film so that carpet takes on
so much more when you're actually
walking it now that you're in a
red-carpet mood and make sure you go to
Oscar calm to check out our amazing
collection of red carpet photo galleries
we'll see you soon